je regardais là-bas prochain très bien
oui oui difficilement mieux c'est quoi
ça j'ai dit mitchell et en plus il
aurait pu être un os un sans faute à un
problème nicolas mingasson si vous
voulez voilà je le disais oss 1001 ça
faisait pas du tout plu pardon ça ne va
pas du tout plu à la baisse avec 4
chiffre s'était apprécié sa jeunesse
m'horripile
mais mon corps bizot dont part en
afrique mais on reste sur la même ligne
il est toujours aussi drôle temps
continue toujours aussi méchant est
toujours un petit peu décalé à la
commande ou ça comme on réalise un bon
tout ça un peu comme les deux premiers
c'est à dire le monde a changé et pas
lui c'est un peu l'idée et le confronter
encore évidemment à ses tourments
et puis et puis à sa genèse cio femmes
et puis à toutes ces idées un peu rance
hier comment jouzor amwaj débarquer un
peu dans une franchise dont je suis
absolument fan
ces jolies chemises en film mince
monnaie merci beaucoup merci je veux
c'est que j'essaie de récupérer parce
que j'aime beaucoup
bonjour et passements il est mais c'est
ainsi que congo mais j'arrête de se
parler de ce slip on est coureur plein
de couleurs non non mais génial jeu
final
moi je débarquais là dedans mais j'avais
surtout l'impression de totalement avoir
le droit de traverser l'écran et de
jouer avec hubert que j'avais admiré et
en tant que cinéphile et qu'un animal de
comédie tellement génial c'était un peu
un cadeau donc j'ai dû effectivement à
peu apprendre les codes de jean françois
halin qui est le scénariste et les codes
du film mais le but c'était un peu aussi
de se sentir plus libre de créer un
nouveau un nouveau duo complètement ci
fonctionne très bien
je sens un mot quand même nicolas votre
tour à cannes après la consécration
l'ovation pura pour la belle époque et
vous prenez pour clôturer ce festival
avec oss 117 ssd merveilleux cadeau
c'est un beau cadeau mais c'est déjà le
cadeau c'est déjà de deux pauvres de
voir le film avec des gens parce qu'on
n'a pas eu l'occasion et je pense qu'à
toulouse
alors évidemment que sa canne c'est
magnifique but mais il est quand même
l'architecte de ces trois fois ses
pilotes
je suis pas mal entouré l'accord
cette première le canon c'est ça moi je
suis venu pour vice versa parce qu'on
avait fait les voix françaises avec
mélanie laurent trottoir et puis j'étais
venu une fois il ya très longtemps avec
toute l'équipe du guédiguian on était 40
à monter les matchs pour l'armée du
crime où j'avais un petit rôle
avec virginie ledoyen simon abkarian et
et voilà mais mais je vais comme une
première fois je suis très content super
encore
ça pourrait marcher beaucoup à tout à
l'heure